this week
because of the evaporation you can say
it's natural air conditioning
from la to berlin to singapore cities
are on the front lines of the climate
crisis
what can they do to adapt to an
uncertain future
air pollution is really according to the
who
the world's greatest environmental
health threat
and we are simply not doing enough
against it air pollution
is a silent killer in urban environments
around the world
we'll be talking to one company
collecting data to combat the problem
if we continue along today's path then
that sets us up for a future where
air conditioning may actually become one
of our single largest source of
greenhouse gas
emissions and harnessing the power of
the night sky to keep buildings cool
without heating the planet why it's high
time for an ac
redesign i'm kaylee lynes and this
is bloomberg green
[Music]
more than half of humanity is crowded
together in cities
that's about 4 billion people living on
top of one another
working commuting and polluting they're
responsible for about
75 percent of greenhouse gas emissions
and that proportion will only rise by
2050 the united nations says almost 70
percent of the world's population
will live in urban areas more cities
than ever
are implementing measures to fight
climate change and mitigate the impact
of extreme weather events on their
communities
and their actions will have the power to
turn the tide on the climate crisis
because no matter how much the world
warms cities will have it worse
high temperatures rising sea levels and
extreme weather are all felt more
acutely
in concrete jungles in germany an
innovative climate adaption strategy is
emerging to tackle these issues
by imitating the very thing cities have
destroyed
nature
[Music]
cities are concrete glass and steel
they look and act unnaturally
absorbing heat and repelling water
our urban spaces are at odds with the
natural environment
but in parts of the german capital
things are different
to deal with rain water and heat
berlin's being transformed into what's
being called
a sponge city
[Music]
their vision is
is the architect of berlin's sponge city
strategy
which harnesses rain water and manages
heat
that's what is
in a natural ecosystem rainwater is
soaked up by soil and vegetation
the majority then evaporates and the
rest
filters deeper into the ground the
evaporating water
then cools the surroundings
[Music]
cities disrupt this system water can't
soak through the concrete
and is piped away
the sponge city strategy aims to keep
rainwater where it lands
to imitate the natural water cycle
buildings are covered in green roofs and
facades
and down on street level urban wetlands
and roadside trenches known as swales
filter runoff and hold water keeping the
city cool
by imitating nature
this is roomsburg in east berlin built
20 years ago
it's become a large-scale example of the
sponge city concept
top we have extensive green roof of
approximately six to eight
centimeters and from there the water
flows into this courtyard here in the
middle
and underneath there is a garage on top
of the
underground garage we have a soil layer
of almost
80 centimeters it's like a sponge and it
soaks the
water during heavy rainfall and then
it's used by the
plants so they take all the water and
finally evaporate it
haiko seeker is the brains behind the
neighborhood's innovative management of
stormwater
in the whole area here we have no storm
fuel system
so no conventional pipe system
the water flows from the road surface
into this whale and from here it's
infiltrating
into the ground on hot summer days you
can really feel the
coolness here it's much cooler compared
to other parts of the city because of
the evaporation
you can say it's natural air
conditioning rooms berg's just
one example of a sponge city
neighborhoods across berlin have
implemented similar initiatives
[Music]
but berlin isn't a perfect sponge city
in the middle of summer 2017 the
heaviest rain in a century hit the city
submerging parts underwater and warning
how much work is still to do
in fact the city councils recently
decided all
new developments should manage
stormwater on site in the spirit of the
sponge city
climate change is forcing berlin and
many other cities around the world
to adapt urban environments transforming
them to work with nature
not against it
for more from our quick take team go to
bloomberg.com
or at quicktake on twitter coming up
air pollution kills millions a year but
one startup is providing means to
measure
harmful emissions we'll be speaking to
their ceo about how to clean up
our cities this is bloomberg green
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is bloomberg green i'm jennifer
zabasaja in new york with your green
brief the eu is planning a first of its
kind
border levy to combat climate change it
plans to slot duties on imports of steel
cement and aluminum from countries with
lower environmental standards
the levy will be based on the carbon
costs that domestic producers
already face the g7 is moving to target
environmental crimes the move is about
cracking down on existing offenses
rather than making new laws it wants
companies to better disclose their
impact on the climate
but it falls short of the uk's ambition
for mandatory reporting on climate risks
final details will be ironed out at the
upcoming cop 26
meeting the western u.s is facing its
worst
drought in decades it's off the charts
of
anything recorded in the 20-year history
of the u.s drought monitor
farmers cities and power suppliers are
scrambling for access to water
it's also raising the risk of wildfires
and making tires for an electric vehicle
is a ruthless exercise in compromise
too much stick and the car won't travel
as far on a charge
too little and it will silently slide
off the road
but tire maker michelin says it has
found the perfect balance
after 30 years tinkering with its recipe
adding seven percent additional range to
evs fitting with the tire
next they want to make them fully
recyclable
and that's your green brief
thanks jen well air pollution in cities
is a problem as old as cities themselves
the world health organization says that
9 out of 10 people breathe air that
exceeds
safe levels of pollutants in fact the wh
estimates that air pollution
kills 7 million people worldwide every
year
a first step in tackling this problem
will be accurately measuring harmful
emissions
so that solutions can be effectively
targeted one startup offering the
hardware to do so is breeze technologies
whose pollution sniffing boxes were
recently shortlisted for the 2021
future hamburg award joining me now is
the founder and ceo of the company
robert heineken robert first frame to me
why air quality is so important if you
look at
today's metropolis they just have very
few data points where they're actually
measuring
how air quality is actually developing
over time
and we are aiming to change that so we
want to give
cities municipalities the government
more data into their hands to accurately
understand
where air pollution actually comes from
how it disperses over the city
and also what can be done but even if
policy makers are armed with that data
how do you convince them to act
yeah that's actually one of the biggest
challenges so many cities actually
are not so interested in gathering more
data because it
simply might just uncover additional
problems
but nasa the european space agency
are both launching new satellite
missions that are
going to uncover these challenges anyway
in the next decades
so the cities really have the choice
whether they want to tackle this issue
now
and whether they want to be the ones who
can actually frame the problem the
context
also the solutions that are going to be
implemented or whether they want to wait
until some external party uncovers all
the challenges that they might have
and thereby it gets out of their control
so today is really the point of
time when cities can act on it
themselves
so let's talk about some of those
solutions then let's take hamburg for an
example where i'm based so
here the government very early on
after dieselgate started to close down
roads for diesel vehicles but the data
has actually shown that this was not
very efficient air quality more or less
stayed the same
on another in another neighborhood they
actually
implemented some pedestrian zoning and
there we really saw
it both increased the attractiveness of
shopping areas but it also increased the
usage of public transport which in turn
decreased air pollution and then in
other parts of the city
or i mean in the port for instance um
they are trying to
uh maintain the cruise ships and the
cargo vessels that are landing there
with power from the land side instead of
having them run their own generators and
this of course also in turn
decreases the emissions that are being
caused so we really need to look at
where pollution comes from locally in
the neighborhood and what to do about
that
is it possible to have a major
metropolitan city with
truly clean air
well i would hope to to believe so um
i mean i think it's it's going to be an
ongoing journey and of course
many of the technologies that we need to
get there to really be able to
breathe clean and fresh air also
according to who standards
are still under development i think
electric mobility
will really be one of the key
technologies to enable us to do that
but we also need to think about mass
transit
more public transport making trans
public transport more attractive
and also looking at for instance last my
delivery and how to solve that issue
without having polluting vehicles and
transportation in our cities
aside from emissions and pollution are
there
other areas in which air quality data
can help mitigate
issues well the the climate change issue
of course
so a lot of the air pollutants that we
are tracking like for instance
ozone also particulate matter are at the
same time also climate pollutants
short-lived climate pollutants
so if we tackle the air quality issue in
our cities then at the same time
with the same budget that is being spent
on that
we're actually also on our way to
solving the climate issue
all right robert heineken founder and
ceo of breeze technologies thank you so
much
coming up what's the technology with the
fastest growing appetite for electricity
it's not cars it's air conditioning we
look next at the companies trying to
cool buildings
without heating the planet this
is bloomberg green
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kaylee lymes and this
is bloomberg green heat waves kill more
than
any other extreme weather event more
than tornadoes hurricanes and even
floods
and the urban heat island effect means
that city dwellers are most at risk
how do we combat that air conditioners
but in this instance the solution is
just creating
another problem if things stay as they
are air conditioning will use as much
electricity by 2050
as the entirety of india and china today
so
we took a look at how scientists from
across the globe are harnessing
natural phenomena to drastically
redesign this century-old technology
[Music]
today's air conditioning and
refrigeration systems essentially follow
the same principles that have been
around for about a hundred years
if we continue along today's path then
that sets us up for a future where
air conditioning may actually become one
of our single largest source of
greenhouse gas emissions
later this century
air conditioners have become an
inescapable part of our cities
they operate thanks to refrigerants
chemicals which when released into the
atmosphere of potent
greenhouse gases ac units also require
huge amounts of energy the us uses more
electricity for cooling
than africa does for everything
as it becomes affordable for millions
more people the problems that come with
ac will only get worse
which is why scientists around the world
are searching for solutions
[Music]
here at the national university of
singapore professor chua and his team
are completely rethinking air
conditioning
we need a quantum leap in air
conditioning to save energy
secondly to save our environment what we
have in the lab is next generation of
air conditioners
where it's extremely environmentally
friendly
less energy intensive it doesn't eject
it to the environment and
doesn't need the chemical refrigerant
it's a water-based air conditioning it
requires only one liter of water to
operate for 20 hours
and you can use rain water to power up
the system
but there's a limitation the end needs
to be dry
before you can carry out this process in
the efficient way and that's why there
are two separate stages in this ac
first it dries the air using membranes
that filter the moisture
then the water inside the unit
evaporates taking heat with it
it's close to what most of us experience
every day sweating
the system uses 30 less energy than a
traditional air conditioner
and it's also expected to be 30 cheaper
crucially it uses no refrigerants and
although it's not available yet the
government is backing this project
betting that soon it could be a breath
of fresh air for singapore and beyond
[Music]
across the other side of the world one
startup in california
is looking towards outer space to
revolutionize cooling
and they're about to test their
breakthrough in the field right now if
we measure the temperature of our
surface it's around 48 degrees
fahrenheit
and the air temperature is 60 fahrenheit
we're not evaporating water
and we're not using any electricity you
can see we're in the middle of a field
and it is just a thin film coating that
enables this cooling effect
and it does this 24 hours a day seven
days a week
skycoa systems is commercializing a
technology that
harnesses the cold of the sky and space
to enable electricity free cooling
as implausible as that may sound at
first glance
the way it works is it takes advantage
of a
natural phenomenon that allows a surface
that's looking up to the sky
to essentially send out some of its heat
nearly everything on earth gives off
heat in the form of infrared radiation
sky cools panels act like high-tech
mirrors reflecting some of that heat out
to the cold expanse of space
allowing its surface to dip below the
temperature of the surrounding air
skycool's multi-layered film means that
it's now possible to achieve
even during the day the panels could be
added on to today's cooling systems
reducing their energy use by as much as
20
the energy we use for cooling is
expected to grow six-fold by the year
2050
and it's primarily going to be driven in
warmer countries where air conditioning
use is not prevalent today
what excites us about our technology is
that it represents
a unique and completely different way of
handling the cooling problem
by taking use of a resource that's
always been there
the fact that space is cold it's almost
like this has been
literally over our heads for centuries
millennia but it's something we've not
been able to use as a technology
with the demand for air conditioning
skyrocketing using water and the cold
outer space may turn out to be the best
bet we have
for our warming cities
so between fixing the problems of heat
water and pollution
cities have a lot to do to adapt but as
well as facing the greatest problems
our urban environments could also be our
best hope for surviving climate change
let's bring in our green reporter laura
mayon in madrid to talk further about
these solutions
laura as we've seen cities consume
two-thirds of the global energy supply
so aren't they the source of the problem
rather than the solution
well yes they are but uh mainly because
we are the source of the problem uh
emissions by humans are what's making uh
the planet warmer
through our research we have found that
cities warm
more and faster than rural areas
and we feel sea level rise more than
than areas that are not urbanized but
cities can also be a part of this of the
solution just because so many human
beings live in them
so many changes through history have
come from cities
and so much money is invested in cities
and from cities
cities can be part of the solution as
well so if cities want to reduce
carbon emissions what are some of the
most popular solutions
what we're seeing um is a lot of
measures being implemented across the
world at the moment one of the most
popular ones
um is called the 15-minute city which is
this concept that
started in paris but has spread almost
all over the world where
local authorities are trying to make
cities more friendly to people
reduce traffic reduce pollution increase
the number of green areas encourage
people to walk
more all of these things reduce
emissions
and and reduce the city's impact on the
environment
but laura the cities with the biggest
carbon footprint aren't
paris or barcelona they're in emerging
markets
how do we decarbonize those that's uh
the second challenge or that's a big
challenge so cities in emerging markets
are huge
their impact therefore is huge as well
and usually local authorities and even
the states themselves don't have as many
resources
to tackle these issues as a big city
in europe or the us might have and yet
we are seeing and through a bloomberg
green investigation we saw
how many of cities in latin america in
africa and in
asia are implementing very innovative
measures
to address climate change so in a big
city it's not enough
to implement 15-minute city measures
like making streets friendly for
pedestrians
but we have seen cities like bogota the
capital of colombia
trying to implement a massive overhaul
of their public transport system it's
right now
one of the world's biggest rapid bus
uh transit systems in the world this
means that instead of
building very expensive metro lines for
example they use buses
that go through special lanes the city
is now uh this
this system is working now and the city
is now trying to make it electric
to reduce the impact of these buses on
on air pollution and on emissions for
example
if you're tight on resources it's best
to be efficient so what does the
research tell us about the most
efficient ways that cities can go green
that's right so a recent report told us
something quite interesting actually
many cities are not spending the money
where that money is better spent
sometimes it's because
cities can only focus in one thing when
they should be focusing maybe on four or
five
other times it's because these measures
are not the most attractive or the most
popular ones with citizens
but for example we know that research
tells us that the most efficient way of
spending money
to address climate issues in cities is
to address building efficiency make
buildings more efficient
so they leak less heat they need less
energy to be heated or cooled
also public transport measures waste
and green areas are some of the fields
where the money can be well spent
thanks very much to our bloomberg green
reporter in madrid laura leon
that's it for this week's edition on the
future of cities but keep the
conversation going
follow us on twitter at climate i'm
kaylee lynes
this is bloomberg green
you